Before we begin today's episode, please be aware that we will be discussing suicide and mental health struggles. If you or someone you know is struggling or in crisis, help is available. You are not alone. Call or text 988-988 lifeline.org to reach the suicide and crisis lifeline. Services are free, confidential, and available 24-7. Each year, nearly 50,000 Americans die by suicide, and suicide is the second leading cause of death among people ages 15 to 34, according to the American Foundation for Suicide Prevention. Many millions more experienced suicidal thoughts, and one of the biggest challenges in suicide prevention, is figuring out who is most at risk and when that risk is greatest. Researchers have spent decades trying to answer those questions, but suicide remains difficult to predict. Now, though, new technologies and research methods are giving scientists new ways to study suicide risk in real time.
在开始今天的节目之前，请注意我们将讨论自杀和心理健康困扰。如果您或您认识的人正处于挣扎或危机中，请寻求帮助。您并不孤单。请拨打或发送短信至 988，或访问 lifeline.org 联系自杀与危机生命线。服务免费、保密，且全天候 24 小时提供。根据美国自杀预防基金会的数据，每年有近 5 万名美国人死于自杀，自杀是 15 至 34 岁人群的第二大死因。还有数百万人经历过自杀念头，而自杀预防中最大的挑战之一，就是找出谁的风险最高，以及何时风险最大。研究人员花费了数十年时间试图回答这些问题，但自杀仍然难以预测。不过，现在新技术和研究方法正在为科学家提供实时研究自杀风险的新途径。
So why is it so hard to predict who will attempt suicide and how are new technologies changing what we know about suicide risk and prevention? What interventions are available to help? And what can you do if you're worried about someone in your life? life. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Matthew Knock, the Edgar Pierce Professor of Psychology at Harvard University, and co-director of the Center for Suicide Research and Prevention at Harvard and Mass General Brigham. His research aims to advance our understanding of why people behave in ways that are harmful to themselves with an
那么，为什么预测谁会尝试自杀如此困难？新技术又是如何改变我们对自杀风险和预防的认知的？有哪些干预措施可以提供帮助？如果您担心生活中的某个人，您能做些什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是哈佛大学 Edgar Pierce 心理学教授、哈佛大学与麻省总医院布里格姆分校自杀研究与预防中心联合主任 Matthew Nock 博士。他的研究旨在增进我们对人们为何会做出伤害自己行为的理解，重点在于
emphasis on suicide and other forms of self-harm. He uses a range of methods, including epidemiologic surveys, lab-based experiments, and clinic-based studies to better understand how these behaviors develop, how to predict them, and how to prevent them. His work has been funded by grants from the National Institutes of Health and several private foundations and has been published in more than 300 scientific papers and book chapters. In 2011, he was awarded a MacArthur Fellowship, also known as a genius grant. Dr. Knock, thank you for joining me. Thank you so much for having me on. And thanks for covering this topic as well. Really appreciate it. Absolutely. It's very important. And I want to start by saying, I read a quote from you saying that the suicide rate in the U.S. hasn't really
自杀和其他形式的自残。他利用一系列方法，包括流行病学调查、实验室实验和临床研究，以更好地了解这些行为是如何发展的、如何预测它们以及如何预防它们。他的工作得到了美国国立卫生研究院和多家私人基金会的资助，并已在 300 多篇科学论文和书籍章节中发表。2011 年，他获得了麦克阿瑟奖，也被称为“天才奖”。Nock 博士，感谢您参加我的节目。非常感谢邀请我参加。也感谢您报道这个话题。我真的很感激。当然，这非常重要。我想先从我读到的一句您的话开始，您说美国的自杀率在过去 100 年里并没有真正
budged in 100 years, although we've made great progress against many other leading causes of death. So let's start there. Why is it so hard to predict and prevent suicide? Yeah, that's a great question. And if I can, I'll qualify the quote a little bit. The suicide rate now in this year is virtually identical to what it was 100 years ago. So that's the big top line finding. The rate does ebb and flow. So if you read, newspapers, you'll say, well, the suicide rate has gone up the past 20 years. Sure, but it went down the 20 years before that. So I think zooming out, I think what's most striking for me is, is the rate hasn't really changed. And if you look at other leading causes of death, heart disease,
发生变化，尽管我们在许多其他主要死因的防治上取得了巨大进展。那么我们就从这里开始吧。为什么预测和预防自杀如此困难？是的，这是一个很好的问题。如果可以的话，我想对这句话稍作限定。今年现在的自杀率与 100 年前几乎完全相同。所以这是最主要的核心发现。自杀率确实会有波动。所以如果你读报纸，你会说，嗯，过去 20 年自杀率上升了。确实，但在那之前的 20 年里它下降了。所以我认为从宏观角度来看，最让我震惊的是，自杀率并没有真正改变。如果你看看其他主要死因，心脏病、
cancers, pneumonia, tuberculosis, motor vehicle accidents, the mortality rate for each of those has plummeted in the past 100 years, not so for suicide. So that's the big, I think, important contrast. Why is that? I think the reason is for all of those other causes of death, we've paid a lot of attention to them. We've allocated funding and significant scientific efforts
癌症、肺炎、肺结核、机动车事故，过去 100 年里每种疾病的死亡率都大幅下降，但自杀并非如此。所以我认为这是一个非常重要的对比。为什么会这样？我认为原因在于，对于所有其他死因，我们给予了极大的关注。我们分配了资金和重大的科学努力
to try and understand them and predict them and prevent them. And we've translated those findings into action. There's huge campaigns decades ago for wearing seatbelts. We talked a lot more about motor vehicle accidents and the importance of wearing seatbelts. And people wear them a lot more now and people die less from motor vehicle accidents. HIV AIDS came on and we didn't cure it, but we developed amazing interventions that now decreased suffering and increased length of life. Not so for suicide. We haven't had the same advances.
来试图理解、预测和预防它们。并且我们将这些发现转化为行动。几十年前，人们开展了大规模的运动来推广系安全带。我们谈论了很多关于机动车事故以及系安全带的重要性。现在人们系安全带的频率高多了，死于机动车事故的人也少了。艾滋病出现时，我们虽然没有治愈它，但我们开发了惊人的干预措施，现在减少了痛苦并延长了寿命。但自杀并非如此。我们没有取得同样的进展。
And for me, that's the thing we really need to talk about and focus on. And I think it's largely because of stigma, that it's still, people are still afraid to talk about suicide to focus on suicide and do the things that are required to make the same changes in this area. So all the more reason I'm glad that this podcast is focusing on this topic, just trying to be part of the solution. How common are suicidal thoughts and what percentage of people who think about suicide actually attempted? Yeah. When we do surveys or we find a large representative sample of the population and ask, have you ever in your life had serious thoughts of suicide? Around the world, 9% of people say, yes, I have.
对我来说，这是我们真正需要讨论和关注的问题。我认为这很大程度上是因为污名化，人们仍然害怕谈论自杀，害怕关注自杀，也不愿采取必要的行动来在这个领域做出同样的改变。所以，我更庆幸这个播客能关注这个话题，我只是想成为解决方案的一部分。自杀念头有多普遍？想过自杀的人中，有多少比例的人真的尝试过？是的。当我们进行调查，或者找到一个具有代表性的大型人口样本并询问“你一生中是否曾有过严重的自杀念头”时，全世界有 9% 的人回答“是的，我有”。
In the U.S., that number is about 15%. So 15% of people in the U.S. say, at some point in my life, I've seriously considered ending my life. Pretty consistently, around the world, a third of people who have that thought will actually make a suicide attempt. So it's 3%, globally, 5% in the U.S. And that ratio is pretty consistent. A third of the people who think about suicide will make an attempt.
在美国，这个数字大约是 15%。也就是说，15% 的美国人表示，在他们生命中的某个时刻，曾认真考虑过结束自己的生命。全世界范围内，大约三分之一有这种想法的人会真正尝试自杀，这个比例相当稳定。所以全球是 3%，美国是 5%。这个比例非常一致。三分之一有自杀念头的人会尝试自杀。
Two-thirds won't. So just having suicidal thoughts is not destiny. Suicidal thoughts are especially common in young people when we do surveys of U.S. high school students, anonymous surveys, so we had a higher yes rate on them because there's not fear of being found out and intervened upon.
三分之二的人不会。所以，仅仅有自杀念头并不意味着命运已定。自杀念头在年轻人中尤其普遍。当我们对美国高中生进行匿名调查时，我们得到的“是”的比例更高，因为他们不担心被发现并受到干预。
And about 20% of high school students in the U.S. say, in the past year, I've thought about killing myself. So one in five of our young people in high school are having these thoughts. So they're not so uncommon developmentally. But it's the acting on them that's rarer. But it's out of pretty common if it's 5% of the time. And is that a pretty steady number with young people or has that changed over time? It's fairly steady. In the past 10 years or so, the numbers from, um,
大约 20% 的美国高中生表示，在过去一年里，我曾想过自杀。所以我们五分之一的高中生都有过这种想法。因此，从发育角度来看，这并不罕见。但付诸行动的情况则较为罕见。不过，如果比例达到 5%，那也相当普遍了。对于年轻人来说，这个数字是相当稳定的，还是随着时间推移发生了变化？相当稳定。在过去 10 年左右的时间里，来自……嗯，
surveys of high school students, some of these rates have ticked up a little bit. So from 2013 to 2023, the rate of high school students saying that they're really sad or hopeless has increased over those 10 years from 30% to 40%. The number of students saying they've seriously considered suicide has increased from 17% to 20%. So they're ticking up slightly over the past decade. There's especially high in girls. Females consistently have higher rates of suicidal thinking and non-lethal suicidal behavior, those identifying as LGBTQ plus, about 40% say that they've had thoughts of suicide in the past year, so especially high rates. And that gender ratio flips for suicide death. Men are four times more likely to die by suicide
高中生调查的数据显示，其中一些比率略有上升。从 2013 年到 2023 年，表示自己非常悲伤或绝望的高中生比例在过去 10 年里从 30% 增加到了 40%。表示曾认真考虑过自杀的学生比例从 17% 增加到了 20%。所以过去十年里它们略有上升。在女生中尤其高。女性在自杀念头和非致命性自杀行为方面的比例一直较高；那些认同为 LGBTQ+ 的群体中，约 40% 表示在过去一年中有过自杀念头，所以比例特别高。但这种性别比例在自杀死亡方面会反转。男性死于自杀的可能性是女性的四倍
than are women. And that's true in the U.S. and it's true in every country around the world. And is that because they just tend to use more lethal methods? Yeah, that's the thing. that men are more likely to use firearms and similarly lethal methods, whereas women are still more likely to die by firearms as a method that's the most common one in the U.S. that are more likely than men to use less lethal methods, overdose, and so on. Right. Now, we know that things like previous suicide attempts, mental illness, and substance use, are associated with suicide risk, but how good are those factors at predicting what an individual
。这在美国是事实，在世界各国也是事实。这是因为他们倾向于使用更致命的方法吗？是的，就是这样。男性更有可能使用枪支和类似的致命方法，而女性虽然在美国最常见的自杀方法仍然是枪支，但她们比男性更有可能使用毒药过量等致命性较低的方法。没错。现在，我们知道既往自杀企图、精神疾病和药物滥用等因素与自杀风险相关，但这些因素在预测个人
person will do? they're not great. One of the biggest takehomes from suicide research is over the past 50 years, we've identified a lot of risk factors for suicidal, let's say, thoughts, attempts, and death, factors that by their presence are associated with an increased risk of suicidal outcomes. The difficulty is going from knowing that something is a risk factor to figuring out who's at risk and when they're at risk and being actually able to predict and prevent the outcome. Take mental disorders as an example. Studies have shown that 90 to 95% of people who die by suicide had a prior diagnosable mental illness.
行为方面有多准确呢？它们并不太好。自杀研究中最大的收获之一是，在过去 50 年里，我们确定了许多与自杀念头、企图和死亡相关的风险因素，这些因素的存在与自杀结果风险增加有关。困难在于，从知道某事是一个风险因素，到找出谁处于风险中、何时处于风险中，并真正能够预测和预防这一结果，这中间存在差距。以精神障碍为例。研究表明，90% 到 95% 的自杀死亡者曾患有可诊断的精神疾病。
Not diagnosed, diagnosable. It was present. It might or might not have been identified. Well, that's great. So we know that most people who die by suicide had a mental illness. Well, most people with mental illness don't die by suicide. So just knowing that someone has depression doesn't tell us, for instance, whether that that person is going to think about suicide, whether that person's going to make a suicide attempt,
不是被诊断出，而是“可诊断”。它确实存在。它可能被识别出来了，也可能没有。嗯，这很好。所以我们知道大多数自杀死亡者都患有精神疾病。但是，大多数患有精神疾病的人并没有死于自杀。所以，仅仅知道某人患有抑郁症并不能告诉我们，例如，那个人是否会产生自杀念头，那个人是否会尝试自杀，
in what year are they going to do so, in what month, in what week? So for intervention purposes, knowing that a person has risk factors is useful, but where the rubber hits the road, it's much more challenging to convert that into action and prevention. Are the predictors of suicide different for different groups of people? In other words, are they different for adolescents versus young adults versus older folks? If so, how? There are some differences, but there's a lot more commonalities than there are differences. So we've looked at suicidal behavior in children, adolescents, adults, older adults, army soldiers, military veterans, college students, people in at this point, over three dozen countries from around the world as part of this WHO initiative, the World Mental Health Survey.
他们会在哪一年、哪个月、哪一周这样做？因此，对于干预目的而言，知道一个人有风险因素是有用的，但落实到具体行动上，将其转化为行动和预防要困难得多。不同人群的自杀预测因素是否不同？换句话说，青少年、年轻人和老年人的预测因素是否不同？如果是，如何不同？确实存在一些差异，但共同点远多于差异。我们研究了儿童、青少年、成人、老年人、陆军士兵、退伍军人、大学生以及来自世界各地 30 多个国家的人群的自杀行为，这是世界卫生组织“世界心理健康调查”倡议的一部分。
And what's, I think most striking is just a consistency. Mental disorders are important everywhere we look. in every population we look at. Depression is the disorder people think most about. When I think about suicide, it seems to consistently be useful for predicting whether a person has thoughts of suicide, but not who acts on those thoughts.
我认为最引人注目的是这种一致性。在我们观察的每一个群体中，精神障碍在任何地方都很重要。抑郁症是人们想到自杀时最先想到的障碍。它似乎始终有助于预测一个人是否有自杀念头，但不能预测谁会付诸行动。
What predicts acting on the thoughts in terms of mental disorders, are disorders characterized by anxiety and poor behavioral control, intermittent explosive disorder, substance use disorders, and so on. This is true in young people, it's true in adults, as true in military service members,
在精神障碍方面，什么能预测对念头的付诸行动呢？是那些以焦虑和行为控制力差为特征的障碍，如间歇性暴怒障碍、药物滥用障碍等。这在年轻人中是事实，在成年人中是事实，在现役军人中也是事实，
it's true in veterans and so on. So there's a lot of commonalities. There are differences, as you might expect, people in the Army, for instance, have combat-related risk factors that just don't generalize to other groups. For adolescents, having siblings in the home, multiple parents in the home seems to be protective,
在退伍军人中也是如此。所以有很多共同点。正如你所料，确实存在差异。例如，军队中的人有与战斗相关的风险因素，这些因素并不能推广到其他群体。对于青少年来说，家里有兄弟姐妹、有多个监护人似乎具有保护作用，
less of an issue for older people. So there are some differences that around the edges can help us tailor prediction models. But I would say the big finding here is just a consistency across all the different groups that we look at. And one thing I want to not related to any specific risk factor, but I want to say a little bit about what we know about why people die by suicide
这对老年人来说问题较小。所以确实存在一些差异，在边缘地带可以帮助我们调整预测模型。但我认为这里最大的发现就是我们在观察的所有不同群体中都存在一致性。有一件事我不想与任何特定的风险因素联系起来，但我确实想谈谈我们所知道的关于人们为何死于自杀的原因，
to help make sense of some risk factors. And for me, this is really helpful in talking to people at risk and families. It's helpful. When we do qualitative interviews, we sit down and interview people who have tried to kill themselves after the initial emergency of the situation has passed and they're in a state where we can talk to them and interview them. And we say, why did you try and try and kill yourself. Far and away, the most common reason people give about 90% of the time is I wanted to
这有助于理解一些风险因素。对我来说，这在与高危人群及其家人交谈时非常有帮助。当我们进行定性访谈时，我们坐下来采访那些试图自杀的人，在情况的最初紧急状态过去后，当他们处于我们可以与他们交谈和采访的状态时，我们问：“你为什么试图自杀？”绝大多数情况下，大约 90% 的时间，人们给出的最常见原因是：我想
escape some seemingly intolerable circumstance, whether it was how I was feeling, thoughts I was having, a social situation, an interpersonal situation I thought I was in. There was a significant psychological pain that a person's experiencing, a narrowing of perspective in time and in options, and an idea that the only solution I have available to me is trying to end my life to get out of the situation. And that's what we're really trying to wrestle with and understand. So when you ask about risk factors, when I think about risk factors, I think about depression as helping to create the psychological pain that a person wants to escape from. And those other impulse control related factors that predict attempt, helping to generate action in a person when they're in this state of psychological pain. So for the listener, I would, if you're trying to make sense of, well, why do people think?
逃避某种看似无法忍受的情况，无论是我的感受、我的想法、社交环境，还是我所处的人际关系。一个人正在经历巨大的心理痛苦，视角和选择在时间上变得狭窄，并且认为我唯一可用的解决方案就是尝试结束生命以摆脱这种情况。这正是我们真正试图努力理解的。所以当你问及风险因素时，当我想到风险因素时，我认为抑郁症有助于产生一个人想要逃避的心理痛苦。而那些与冲动控制相关的因素则预测了企图，帮助一个人在处于这种心理痛苦状态时产生行动。所以对于听众，如果你试图理解，嗯，为什么人们会产生想法？
think about suicide, why do they try and die by suicide? It is the vast majority of the time about trying to escape from some seemingly intolerable, let's call it psychological pain. How do most clinicians assess the risk of suicide? I mean, what kinds of questions do they ask or should they ask and how do they weigh the different pieces of information and make decisions about, say, somebody who should be hospitalized and somebody who shouldn't? Yeah, that's a fantastic question, and it's actually, those are the exact questions we just asked in a qualitative study that we did with frontline clinicians. And we asked, almost verbatim to what you just asked, how do you assess suicide risk? So if someone's having thoughts of suicide, what we
为什么他们会尝试自杀？绝大多数情况下，这都是为了试图逃避某种看似无法忍受的、我们称之为心理痛苦的东西。大多数临床医生如何评估自杀风险？我的意思是，他们会问什么样的问题，或者应该问什么样的问题？他们如何权衡不同的信息并做出决定，比如谁应该住院，谁不应该？是的，这是一个非常棒的问题，这实际上正是我们在对一线临床医生进行的定性研究中提出的问题。我们几乎逐字逐句地问了你刚才问的问题：你如何评估自杀风险？所以如果有人有自杀念头，我们
encourage people to do is bring that person to an emergency department or call 911 or call 988 in the U.S. the national free anonymous hotline. And when you get to, let's say, the emergency department for those who aren't familiar what happens if you're if you're having thoughts of suicide uh you meet with a clinician just like you would if you had a cut or or or a broken broken wrist or something you meet with a clinician and they ask you questions to try and understand your mental state and to try and make an accurate assessment of whether you are imminent risk for hurting yourself or potentially hurting someone else or if you're unable to care for yourself the sort of standard criteria for determining whether you need a higher level of care, hospitalization, and so on.
鼓励人们做的是把那个人带到急诊室，或者拨打 911，或者在美国拨打 988，即全国免费匿名热线。当你到达急诊室时——对于那些不熟悉的人，如果你有自杀念头，会发生什么？你会像处理割伤、骨折或手腕受伤一样见到临床医生，他们会问你问题，试图了解你的精神状态，并试图准确评估你是否处于伤害自己或可能伤害他人的迫切风险中，或者你是否无法照顾自己。这是确定你是否需要更高水平护理、住院治疗等的标准准则。
And so we are doing research trying to understand, well, what are clinicians naturally asking to make those determinations? And we haven't fully finished analyzing a result, and we haven't published any yet, but I can share that there's great variability in the questions that clinicians are asking to try and understand suicide risk. And there's some variability in how clinicians are making determinations about who requires or might be expected to benefit from hospitalization. On one hand, it might be surprising. Shouldn't we have a standard way of doing this? And everybody asks the same questions.
所以我们正在进行研究，试图了解临床医生在做出这些决定时自然会问什么。我们还没有完全分析完结果，也没有发表任何文章，但我可以分享的是，临床医生在试图了解自杀风险时所问的问题存在很大差异。而且临床医生在决定谁需要或可能从住院治疗中受益方面也存在一些差异。一方面，这可能令人惊讶。我们不应该有一种标准的方法来做这件事吗？每个人都问同样的问题。
And there are some standards. There's standard scales that people use to assess for the presence and severity of suicidal thinking. But clinicians are doing a lot of asking of questions and case conceptualization outside of that. And it's not surprising, then, that there's great variability, given the breadth of risk factors. There's dozens of risk factors for suicide. So how's, and the scales that are standard, don't ask about all those risk factors. So there's a lot of space there for clinicians to ask a lot of
确实有一些标准。人们使用标准量表来评估自杀念头的存在和严重程度。但临床医生在这些量表之外做了大量的提问和案例概念化工作。考虑到风险因素的广泛性，这也就不足为奇了。自杀有几十种风险因素。所以，标准的量表并没有涵盖所有这些风险因素。因此，临床医生有很大的空间去问很多
different questions. And if you think about, you know, who should be hospitalized, there's a lot that goes into that beyond risk. It's not just, is this person at risk for suicide? It's, are they in treatment? Do they have a treatment team outside the hospital that can help keep them safe? What's their family situation? Do they have family members who are working closely with them to try and, uh, ensure their safety and improve their psychological health? Are they stably housed? Have they benefited from hospitalization in the past? So there's a lot of factors that might go into making a decision about hospitalization.
不同的问题。如果你考虑谁应该住院，除了风险之外，还有很多因素。这不仅仅是“这个人有自杀风险吗？”而是：他们是否在接受治疗？他们在医院外是否有治疗团队可以帮助确保他们的安全？他们的家庭情况如何？是否有家庭成员与他们密切合作，试图确保他们的安全并改善他们的心理健康？他们是否有稳定的住所？他们过去是否从住院治疗中受益？所以，在决定是否住院时，有很多因素需要考虑。
It's not such a simple cut and dry thing. There's also exciting new research that came out last summer by Ron Kessler, who is a leading psychiatric epidemiologist at Harvard Medical School, on the benefits of hospitalization for those at risk for suicide, and the variability in outcomes for people. who are hospitalized. And this is going to be cartooning it a little bit, but what he and his team found is,
这并不是一个简单的是非题。去年夏天，哈佛医学院领先的精神病流行病学家 Ron Kessler 发表了一项令人兴奋的新研究，关于住院治疗对自杀高危人群的益处，以及人们在住院后结果的差异。这可能有点简化了，但他和他的团队发现的是，
it seems that not everybody benefits from hospitalization for suicide risk, perhaps not surprisingly. There's been a lot of debate about whether hospitalization is effective or not. And that's a difficult experiment to do because we don't want to not hospitalized people who we think are at risk just to do an experiment. What his study found is that for about half of people it seems to not make a difference, whether they were hospitalized or not in terms of their risk.
似乎并不是每个人都能从自杀风险的住院治疗中受益，这也许并不令人惊讶。关于住院治疗是否有效，一直存在很多争论。这是一个很难进行的实验，因为我们不想为了做实验而不让那些我们认为有风险的人住院。他的研究发现，对于大约一半的人来说，住院与否在风险方面似乎没有区别。
For about a quarter of people, they seem to get much better after a hospitalization. For about the other quarter of people, they seem to do worse after a hospitalization. So maybe it is the case that what happens in a hospital if you're at risk for suicide, intense psychotherapy, some medication management, maybe it's helpful for some people. They really benefit from that higher level of care in the short term. For some people, it doesn't make a difference. for some people, maybe they get worse in some way. We don't know why.
对于大约四分之一的人来说，他们在住院后似乎好多了。对于另外四分之一的人来说，他们在住院后似乎情况更糟了。所以也许确实是这样：如果你有自杀风险，在医院里发生的事情——强化心理治疗、一些药物管理——可能对某些人有帮助。他们确实在短期内从那种更高水平的护理中受益。对某些人来说，这没有区别。对某些人来说，也许他们以某种方式变得更糟了。我们不知道为什么。
We don't know the mechanism yet, and this requires replication and so on. But it's an exciting step forward and starting to think really critically about what is it that we do when someone's at really high risk. And it doesn't seem to be the case that everyone's going to benefit by more care or everyone's going to benefit
我们还不知道机制，这需要重复验证等等。但这是一个令人兴奋的进步，开始真正批判性地思考当某人处于极高风险时我们到底在做什么。而且似乎并不是每个人都会从更多的护理中受益，或者每个人都会从
from what we do in, let's say, a hospitalization. And to get back to your question, so clinicians on the front line are tasked with thinking about, is this patient in front of me going to get better if I make a decision to hospitalize them or not. And if we as researchers haven't yet provided this kind of information to clinicians in the front line in a consistent, reliable, valid way, just highlights from you that there's a lot more work for us to do to try and make the system better and make pathways of care work better than they do now.
我们在住院治疗中所做的事情中受益。回到你的问题，一线临床医生负责思考：如果我决定让他们住院，我面前的病人会好转吗？如果我们作为研究人员还没有以一致、可靠、有效的方式为一线临床医生提供这种信息，这只是向你强调，我们还有很多工作要做，以试图改善系统，并使护理路径比现在运作得更好。
What are the most effective interventions at this point? And how does it differ if, say, somebody is having suicidal thoughts and is not hospitalized, how do they get treated versus somebody who is hospitalized and gets a different level of treatment? I'll start with what happens outside the hospital, although there's some blurring here because things that happen outside the hospital, cognitive behavior therapy, for instance, also is delivered inside the hospital. So there's certainly some consistency across the two. Outside the hospital, in terms of psychological interventions, our strongest effects right now are for psychological treatments like cognitive therapy, cognitive behavior therapy for suicidal behavior.
目前最有效的干预措施是什么？如果有人有自杀念头但没有住院，他们的治疗方式与住院并接受不同水平治疗的人有何不同？我先从医院外发生的事情开始，尽管这里有一些模糊之处，因为医院外发生的事情，例如认知行为疗法，也会在医院内提供。所以两者之间肯定有一些一致性。在医院外，就心理干预而言，我们目前最强的影响是针对心理治疗，如认知疗法、针对自杀行为的认知行为疗法。
There's a specific manualized intervention from Aaron Beck years ago and followed up by Greg Brown and others at University of Pennsylvania. Really excellent intervention for those at risk for suicide. So it takes a classic cognitive therapy, cognitive behavior therapy, and focuses on suicidal behavior risk. Dialectical behavior therapy. has shown pretty consistently to be a really helpful treatment for those at risk for suicide. And there's some newer suicide-focused interventions, one called CAMs, developed by Dave Jobs at Catholic University,
有一个来自 Aaron Beck 多年前制定的特定手册化干预措施，随后由宾夕法尼亚大学的 Greg Brown 和其他人跟进。对于自杀高危人群来说，这确实是非常好的干预措施。它采用了经典的认知疗法、认知行为疗法，并专注于自杀行为风险。辩证行为疗法（DBT）已被证明对于自杀高危人群来说是一种非常有效的治疗方法。还有一些较新的以自杀为重点的干预措施，一种叫做 CAMS，由天主教大学的 Dave Jobs 开发，
which is a collaborative approach to suicide risk where the clinician talks with a client, a patient, about what of the motivations, the drivers of their suicidal thinking and risk for suicidal behavior, and tries to validate those and approach them in a really collaborative way, a really exciting, new-ish intervention that's been made available. So there are some suicide-focused psychological interventions. I say suicide-focused in that they're designed specifically for people at risk for suicide, and they talk with the patient, the client, about suicide. They don't shy away from it.
这是一种针对自杀风险的协作方法，临床医生与客户、患者讨论自杀念头和自杀行为风险的动机、驱动因素是什么，并试图验证这些动机并以非常协作的方式处理它们。这是一种非常令人兴奋的、较新的干预措施。所以有一些以自杀为重点的心理干预措施。我之所以说以自杀为重点，是因为它们是专门为自杀高危人群设计的，而且它们会与患者、客户谈论自杀。它们不会回避它。
It's to try to understand the motivation. What are you trying to accomplish with efforts in your life? And how can we teach you, work with you to help you develop skills that alleviate that pain, that teach you alternative ways of monitoring and, and managing that pain and help you build a life worth living. How do we increase the protective factors and the meaning in your life and the connections in your life? And that's in a nutshell, again, I'm cartooning this a little bit, but this is what these treatments
这是为了试图理解动机。你试图通过生活中的努力实现什么？我们如何教你、与你合作，帮助你培养减轻这种痛苦的技能，教你监测和管理这种痛苦的替代方法，并帮助你建立一个值得活下去的生活？我们如何增加保护因素以及你生活中的意义和联系？简而言之，我再次简化了这一点，但这就是这些治疗
are trying to do. And there's evidence that they work, that they work for decreasing their risk of suicidal behavior. Those are largely historically developed and tested and implemented outside of hospitals. But increasingly, and there's some exciting work right now happening to try and tailor these interventions for use in inpatient settings. So make them very brief so they can be administered during a, let's say, five-day inpatient stay, and then followed after patients leave the hospital. So you learn some skills in the hospital when you're at this really high-risk period,
试图做的事情。有证据表明它们有效，它们能降低自杀行为的风险。这些在历史上主要是在医院外开发、测试和实施的。但越来越多的人正在进行一些令人兴奋的工作，试图调整这些干预措施以用于住院环境。所以让它们变得非常简短，以便可以在例如五天的住院期间进行，然后在患者出院后进行跟踪。这样你在处于这个高风险时期时在医院里学到了一些技能，
and then they get used and developed further when you leave. There's also pharmacological interventions that have shown to be effective. Mood stabilizers like lithium for people with bipolar disorder that seem to have anti-suicidal properties. There's evidence of people who get lithium with bipolar disorder, have lower risk of suicidal behavior, clausoryl for people with psychotic illness and so on. So there do seem to be some medications that work especially well for people out of risk for suicide.
然后当你离开时，它们会被使用并进一步发展。还有一些药物干预措施已被证明是有效的。例如双相情感障碍患者使用的情绪稳定剂（如锂盐），似乎具有抗自杀特性。有证据表明，服用锂盐的双相情感障碍患者，自杀行为的风险较低；氯氮平对于精神病患者等等。所以确实似乎有一些药物对自杀高危人群特别有效。
And I mentioned bipolar disorder is a really high-risk disorder. 20% of people with bipolar disorder, sadly, will die by suicide. So it's really important that we try and develop effective interventions and anti-suicidal interventions for people at high risk. And lastly, and moving back to in-paysal. care. There's some really exciting psychiatric work happening on trying to develop more fast-acting treatments for people at risk for suicide. Listeners may have heard about the uses of ketamine as an antidepressant and anti-suicidal drug option. There's a lot of work now testing. How can we
我提到双相情感障碍是一种极高风险的障碍。遗憾的是，20% 的双相情感障碍患者会死于自杀。因此，我们努力为高危人群开发有效的干预措施和抗自杀干预措施非常重要。最后，回到住院护理。在尝试为自杀高危人群开发更快速起效的治疗方法方面，正在进行一些非常令人兴奋的精神病学工作。听众可能听说过氯胺酮作为抗抑郁药和抗自杀药物选择的用途。现在有很多工作在测试。我们如何
get it to work for more and more people? Doesn't seem to work well for everyone. How durable are the effects of ketamine? ECT electroconvulsive therapy I know has a controversial history and some people have a concern with the ethics of administering shock to people but it does seem to be really effective for people with treatment-resistant depression
让它对越来越多的人有效？它似乎并不对每个人都有效。氯胺酮的效果能持续多久？我知道电休克疗法（ECT）有争议的历史，有些人担心对人进行电击的伦理问题，但它对于治疗抵抗性抑郁症患者似乎确实非常有效，
and it does seem to have pretty strong anti-suicidal properties. So in extreme cases when other interventions aren't working, it does seem to be an effective option. And perhaps related in terms of brain stimulation, Transcranial magnetic stimulation using magnets to try and change the activity of different brain circuits in a really targeted way. Also seems to have pretty good antidepressant and maybe antisoicidal properties.
而且它似乎确实具有相当强的抗自杀特性。因此，在其他干预措施无效的极端情况下，它似乎是一个有效的选择。也许在脑刺激方面，经颅磁刺激（TMS）利用磁铁以非常有针对性的方式改变不同大脑回路的活动，似乎也具有相当好的抗抑郁和可能的抗自杀特性。
And this is the treatment that's administered a few times a week for a number of weeks outpatient traditionally. And now researchers are experimenting with accelerated versions of TMS, transcranomagnetic stimulation, where you might get many treatments per day in a hospitalization to trillate, make the treatment more compact, so give you more sessions in an accelerated timeline, and that does seem to have good effects on depression, and we're experimenting how can that be used as a fast-acting treatment for suicide.
这是一种传统上每周在门诊进行几次、持续数周的治疗。现在研究人员正在尝试加速版本的 TMS，你可能在住院期间每天接受多次治疗，以使治疗更紧凑，从而在加速的时间表内提供更多疗程。这似乎对抑郁症有很好的效果，我们正在试验如何将其用作自杀的快速起效治疗。
For me, it's a really exciting time, seeing interventions like these, ketamine, ECT, TMS, psychedelics are also getting increasingly experimented with, and bringing these to hospital settings where we have people for just a few days, when they're in this really high-risk state and testing, can we really turn levers in a targeted way and try and decrease people's risk while we have them safely
对我来说，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻，看到像氯胺酮、ECT、TMS、迷幻药这样的干预措施也越来越多地被试验，并将这些带入医院环境——我们让人们在那里待几天，当他们处于这种极高风险状态时——并测试：我们能否以有针对性的方式拨动杠杆，并在我们安全地
being treated in the hospital? This is especially important because the absolute highest risk time for dying by suicide is in the weeks after a hospitalization for psychiatric risk, which maybe is a little counterintuitive. You think if we get a person into psychiatric care, they're now going to be, you know, they're sort of out of the woods, but statistically speaking, the rate of suicide death skyrockets after discharge from a hospitalization. And I don't think that's because hospital is making people
在医院治疗他们时，试图降低人们的风险？这一点尤为重要，因为死于自杀的绝对最高风险时间是在因精神风险住院后的几周内，这可能有点违反直觉。你认为如果我们让一个人接受精神科护理，他们现在就会，你知道，他们算是脱离危险了，但从统计学上讲，自杀死亡率在出院后会飙升。我不认为这是因为医院让人
suicidal. I think what's happening is we're doing a good job in the front end. We're finding people at risk. We're getting them into the hospital. We're getting them inpatient care. But we haven't yet identified strong enough interventions. And we aren't yet doing a good enough job monitoring people when they leave. What we do for suicide, what we do for psychiatric care, for psychological care, looks very different than what we do in heart disease and stroke in other areas of medicine where we do really careful monitoring of people. And we develop interventions that tailor treatment to the person based on scans that we're doing in a continuous way, think about heart disease. And we do intensive cardiac rehab after a person leaves a hospital after our heart attack.
产生自杀念头。我认为发生的情况是，我们在前端做得很好。我们发现了高危人群。我们让他们住院。我们让他们接受住院护理。但我们还没有确定足够强大的干预措施。而且当他们离开时，我们还没有做好足够的监测工作。我们为自杀所做的、我们为精神科护理、心理护理所做的，看起来与我们在心脏病、中风和其他医学领域所做的非常不同，在那些领域，我们对人们进行非常仔细的监测。我们开发干预措施，根据我们持续进行的扫描来为个人量身定制治疗方案，想想心脏病。我们在心脏病发作后，在一个人离开医院后进行密集的康复治疗。
for suicide, what we do is hospitalize someone, and then when they leave, we make a recommendation that they follow up and get outpatient care, see a psychologist, see a social worker, see a psychiatrist, but there's not the same level of follow-up that there is for other areas of medicine. So this is something that we're trying to get better at. Let's talk for a moment about technology. I know a lot of your work has focused on the use of technology and suicide prediction and prevention. Tell us more about that work. I mean, what kind of studies have you done and what are you finding? Here, too, I'm really excited. I think it's a really exciting time in our ability to understand, predict, and prevent suicide because of the kinds of technologies that are being developed. So I've been working in this area for 25, 30 years. And for all of this time and for many years, I know before, we've been sort of wringing our hands. Sorry, this is a roundabout answer to your short question. Ringing your hands because there's some challenging aspects of suicide. It's a low base rate behavior. So although it's a leading cause.
对于自杀，我们所做的是让某人住院，然后当他们离开时，我们建议他们跟进并接受门诊护理，看心理学家、社会工作者、精神科医生，但没有像其他医学领域那样同等水平的后续跟进。所以这是我们正在努力改进的地方。让我们谈谈技术。我知道你的很多工作都集中在技术在自杀预测和预防中的应用。告诉我们更多关于那项工作的信息。我的意思是，你做了什么样的研究，你发现了什么？在这里，我也感到非常兴奋。我认为由于正在开发的技术种类，这是我们理解、预测和预防自杀能力方面一个非常令人兴奋的时刻。所以我在这个领域工作了 25、30 年。在所有这些时间里，在很多年前，我知道之前，我们一直在某种程度上束手无策。抱歉，这是对你简短问题的迂回回答。束手无策，因为自杀有一些具有挑战性的方面。这是一种低基准率的行为。所以虽然它是主要死因，
of death, it doesn't happen a lot in time and place. And it seems to be caused by the complex interaction of many different risk factors. We're doing specific studies to try and get better at prediction and prevention, but it's from this perspective of we've done this in other areas, can't we do the same thing here using the same kind of logic and data? So we're doing things like using electronic health record data that gets collected on all of us. Right. So you, I, hopefully, on some cadence, go to see our primary care doctor, maybe we go to see an outpatient therapist, maybe we get inpatient care,
但它在时间和地点上并不经常发生。而且它似乎是由许多不同风险因素的复杂相互作用引起的。我们正在进行具体的研究以试图在预测和预防方面做得更好，但这是基于我们已经在其他领域做过这些事情的视角，我们不能在这里使用同样的逻辑和数据吗？所以我们正在做一些事情，比如使用我们所有人身上收集的电子健康记录数据。没错。所以你、我，希望在某种频率下，去看我们的初级保健医生，也许我们去看门诊治疗师，也许我们接受住院护理，
and the doctors generate little numeric codes each time they see us and treat us and bill us, indicating what kind of problems, conditions we came in with and what kind of interventions were provided. That all gets, it used to be written down on pencil and paper and put in file folders and slid in a filing cabinet, as you and I may remember. Now, all of that's digitized.
医生每次见到我们、治疗我们并向我们收费时，都会生成小的数字代码，表明我们带着什么样的问题、状况进来，以及提供了什么样的干预措施。所有这些，过去是写在纸和笔上，放在文件夹里，滑进文件柜里，正如你和我可能记得的那样。现在，所有这些都数字化了。
So it's all zeros and ones, you know, on a server somewhere, what we found is we can apply statistical learning to those numbers and extract from them risk factors on the things that we know are important bipolar disorder do you have a bipolar disorder diagnosis do you have a depression diagnosis have you taken antidepressant have you said that you've experienced pain we can extract information from a lot of risk factors weight them add them up make a prediction about whether each patient's going to make a suicide attempt or die by suicide and we're getting pretty accurate predictions on whether someone's going to make a suicide attempt in the next month, are they going to die by suicide in the next year? Not perfect by any stretch. There's a lot of
所以它们都是服务器上某处的零和一。我们发现我们可以将统计学习应用于这些数字，并从中提取我们知道很重要的风险因素：双相情感障碍，你是否有双相情感障碍诊断？你是否有抑郁症诊断？你是否服用过抗抑郁药？你是否说过你经历过疼痛？我们可以从很多风险因素中提取信息，给它们加权，把它们加起来，对每个病人是否会尝试自杀或死于自杀做出预测。我们对某人是否会在下个月尝试自杀、是否会在下一年死于自杀的预测变得相当准确。绝非完美。我们的预测中有很多
error in our predictions. We have a lot of false positives. A lot of time the flag goes up saying this person's going to make a suicide attempt and they don't. And that's something we've got to wrestle with and there's a lot of debate in the field about how accurate do we need to be. How should we consider false positives, false negatives and so on. But in the past 10 years, these models have gotten increasingly accurate and I think increasingly actionable. So that's a big focus of our work now as I'm trying to use data that we already have in hand to get better at identifying which patients in our healthcare system are at high risk. And so we should attend more to decrease their likelihood of dying by suicide.
错误。我们有很多假阳性。很多时候，旗帜升起说这个人会尝试自杀，但他们没有。这是我们必须努力解决的问题，领域内对于我们需要多准确存在很多争论。我们应该如何考虑假阳性、假阴性等等。但在过去 10 年里，这些模型变得越来越准确，我认为也越来越具有可操作性。所以这是我们现在工作的重点，因为我试图利用我们手中已有的数据，更好地识别我们医疗系统中的哪些病人处于高风险中。因此，我们应该更多地关注以降低他们死于自杀的可能性。
Another part of our work then picks up from there and says, now that we know someone's at risk in the next year, say, you get a person who their profile suggests they've got let's say a 40% chance of making a suicide attempt in the next year, but we don't know when. So we're doing in another line of work, we're following people by putting apps with their permission on their smartphone, and we're passively monitoring signals from their phone
我们工作的另一部分从那里开始，并说：既然我们知道某人在下一年处于风险中，比如说，你有一个人，他们的资料显示他们有 40% 的机会在下一年尝试自杀，但我们不知道是什么时候。所以我们在另一项工作中，我们通过在他们的智能手机上安装应用程序（在他们许可的情况下）来跟踪人们，我们正在被动地监测来自他们手机的信号。
or from a wrist-worn device. And we're getting, you know, simple stuff. We're sending people surveys, asking them, how are you doing today? What's your mood like? Are you alone? Are you with other people? Are you having any thoughts of suicide? And we're getting simple stuff.
或者来自腕戴式设备。我们正在获取一些简单的信息。我们向人们发送调查问卷，询问他们：你今天过得怎么样？你的心情如何？你是一个人吗？你和别人在一起吗？你有自杀的想法吗？我们正在获取这些简单的信息。
about sleep and steps and GPS, are you in parks or are you in church or are you in liquor stores? Are you connected with other people? Are you calling and texting them? Are they calling and texting you? And we're getting some exciting findings. We just, we published a paper just recently in one of the APA journals, Journal of Psychopathology and Clinical Science, showing that we can we can identify in some of our best models about 87% of suicide attempts and hospitalizations to prevent a suicide attempt a week before they happen, just from the survey data. This isn't yet fully in all of the other sources of data that we have, step count and sleep and voice data samples we're getting and so on. And in a separate line of work, we're developing
关于睡眠、步数和GPS，你是在公园里，还是在教堂里，或者是在酒类商店里？你是否与他人有联系？你是否在给他们打电话或发短信？他们是否在给你打电话或发短信？我们正在获得一些令人兴奋的发现。我们最近在APA期刊之一《精神病理学与临床科学杂志》上发表了一篇论文，表明在一些最好的模型中，我们可以在自杀企图发生前一周，仅凭调查数据就能识别出约87%的自杀企图和住院治疗。这还没有完全整合我们拥有的所有其他数据源，比如步数、睡眠、我们获取的语音数据样本等等。在另一条研究线上，我们正在开发
and testing digital interventions that can be deployed to people right in time. So they're called just in time adaptive interventions. So it's Friday at 6 p.m. I see my clinician, I have a Tuesday morning and Friday at 6 p.m., my risk starts increasing. What do I do? How do I manage? How do I, do I wait until I see my clinician on Tuesday? Well, through our model, we're finding when people are at risk and we're deploying different kinds of interventions and we're doing little experiments to see what's the right intervention for the right level of risk for this person, to try and bring care to people when they need it, rather than relying only on our traditional psychotherapy model, which is coming to come in.
并测试可以及时部署给人们的数字干预措施。它们被称为“即时自适应干预”。比如现在是周五下午6点。我去看我的临床医生，我有周二早上和周五下午6点的预约，我的风险开始增加。我该怎么办？我该如何应对？我该等到周二去看我的临床医生吗？好吧，通过我们的模型，我们正在发现人们何时处于风险之中，并部署不同类型的干预措施。我们正在做一些小实验，看看对于这个人的风险水平，什么是正确的干预措施，试图在人们需要时提供护理，而不是仅仅依赖我们传统的心理治疗模式，即来到
in to a brick and mortar clinic or log in to, you know, Zoom these days and see your clinician at once a week at a predetermined time. I think this is not a sufficient model to treat the ebb and flow of suicidal thoughts or alcohol use urges or drug urges or urges to binge and purge and so on. A lot of the behaviors that people struggle with don't follow the timeline of our predetermined psychotherapy sessions. So we're using new technology to try and respond to that and wrap treatment around the person rather than waiting for the person to come to us. I want to ask about the role of chatbots in this situation. I mean, are they for good or for ill in this case?
实体诊所，或者像现在这样登录Zoom，在预定的时间每周见一次临床医生。我认为这不足以应对自杀念头、饮酒冲动、药物冲动或暴饮暴食冲动等的起伏。人们挣扎的许多行为并不遵循我们预定的心理治疗时间表。因此，我们正在利用新技术来尝试应对这一点，并将治疗围绕在人身边，而不是等待人们来找我们。我想问一下聊天机器人在这种情况下的作用。我的意思是，在这种情况下，它们是利大于弊还是弊大于利？
Yeah, it's a great question, and it's one that people are talking a lot about now, and there's a lot of signs coming out about this. I think of chatbots the same way I think about the Internet and the telephone and lots of new technology, dating back to, you know, the sharp object, is it used to, you know, cure disease and perform life-saging saving surgeries, or is it used to, you know, attack someone else? These are implements. These are tools, and it's up to us as humans to determine how we're going to use them for good or for evil, and they can be used in any direction we want. I'm optimistic about the
是的，这是一个很好的问题，也是人们现在讨论很多的问题，而且有很多关于这方面的迹象出现。我把聊天机器人看作我对待互联网、电话和许多新技术的方式，追溯到，你知道，锋利的物体，它是被用来，你知道，治愈疾病和进行挽救生命的各种手术，还是被用来，你知道，攻击别人？这些是工具。这些是工具，作为人类，我们有责任决定如何利用它们来行善或作恶，它们可以朝着我们想要的任何方向使用。我对
possibilities of using chatbots, of using large language models, as you can talk on my responses, that's using technology to try and help people. I talked about hand-wringing earlier that we've been doing for decades. A lot of what many of us have been lamenting for the past few decades is there's a lot of unmet need in terms of psychological illness, psychiatric illness. A lot of people struggle with depression and anxiety
使用聊天机器人、使用大型语言模型的可能性持乐观态度，正如你可以谈论我的回答一样，这是利用技术来尝试帮助人们。我之前谈到了我们几十年来一直在做的焦虑不安。我们许多人在过去几十年里一直在感叹的很多事情是，在心理疾病、精神疾病方面存在大量未满足的需求。许多人与抑郁和焦虑作斗争
and suicidal thoughts. And the average length of time that someone goes struggling with an illness, a mental illness, before they get treatment, is around eight years or so, eight to 10 years. There are evidence-based treatments available. Most people don't have access to them.
以及自杀念头。一个人在接受治疗前与疾病、精神疾病作斗争的平均时间大约是八年左右，八到十年。有循证治疗方法可用。大多数人无法获得这些治疗。
And there's great inequities in access to care based on how much what your income is, where you live, what part of the country of the world you live in. There might not be a psychologist or a psychiatrist for hundreds of miles. If only there was some way of democratizing treatment and making evidence-based psychological interventions
而且在获得护理的机会方面存在巨大的不平等，这取决于你的收入是多少，你住在哪里，你住在国家或世界的哪个部分。可能方圆数百英里内都没有心理学家或精神科医生。如果有什么方法能让治疗民主化，并使循证心理干预措施
available to everybody when they needed them for a very low, cost were for free. And I think large language models, chatpots provide the opportunity to do that. Now, it's not a given. It's, you know, we've got to think carefully about this and be thoughtful and design them and program them and guardrail them in a way that leads them to provide helpful interactions. But I think it's for us to figure out how to do that. And for scientists and clinicians and health care providers and folks in the industry to work together to try and use these tools to help improve human health and functioning. But there's errors that can be made along the way,
在人们需要时以非常低的成本或免费提供给每个人，那该多好。我认为大型语言模型、聊天机器人提供了这样做的机会。当然，这不是必然的。你知道，我们必须仔细考虑这一点，深思熟虑，设计它们、编程它们，并以一种引导它们提供有益互动的方式设置护栏。但我认为我们有责任弄清楚如何做到这一点。科学家、临床医生、医疗保健提供者和行业人士需要共同努力，尝试利用这些工具来帮助改善人类的健康和功能。但在过程中可能会犯错误，
and there's wrong ways of doing this that can certainly lead to harm as there are for any field or any new tool. I want to close out by asking for some practical advice for our listeners. What should parents, friends, relatives do if they know someone or they think someone they know is at risk of suicide? Should they talk to the people about it? I mean, how can you move past the fear of saying the wrong thing, starting the conversation and being helpful. Yeah. Great question. I'm glad you asked it. It's probably the most common question I get when I talk about suicide and, you know, to public groups is, what should I do? And isn't there harm in asking? This has been a fear for forever since I can remember. If I asked someone if the right was for suicide,
而且这样做有错误的方法，当然会导致伤害，就像任何领域或任何新工具一样。我想最后请您为我们的听众提供一些实用的建议。如果父母、朋友、亲戚知道某人或认为他们认识的人有自杀风险，他们应该怎么做？他们应该和这些人谈谈吗？我的意思是，你如何克服说错话的恐惧，开始对话并提供帮助？是的。很好的问题。我很高兴你问了这个问题。当我向公众团体谈论自杀时，这可能是我得到的最常见的问题，即我该怎么办？询问难道没有害处吗？从我记事起，这一直是一种恐惧。如果我问某人是否想自杀，
maybe that will give them the idea and it will be my fault. I will have made things worse. And at this point, there have been many experiments on this exact question and the results are very consistent. It is not harmful to ask people about suicide. It does not give people the idea to ask people about suicide. And the same way it doesn't ask people about homicide. Are you thinking about killing someone? No, but now that you mentioned it, now I'm going to go kill someone. It doesn't work that way.
也许那会给他们这个想法，那将是我的错。我会把事情变得更糟。在这一点上，关于这个确切的问题已经进行了许多实验，结果非常一致。询问人们关于自杀的问题并没有害处。询问人们关于自杀的问题并不会给他们这个想法。同样，询问人们关于他杀的问题也不会。你在考虑杀人吗？不，但既然你提到了，现在我要去杀人了。事情不是那样运作的。
Humans don't operate that way. And the same is true for suicide. And the first landmark study on this was by Maddie Gould at Columbia in 2005. and it was published in the journal Jama for those who are interested. And she did an experiment and asked some kids about suicide and not the others and then filed them up. And people who were asked about suicide were not more distressed, were not more likely to think about suicide, we're not more likely to engage in suicidal behavior.
人类不是那样运作的。自杀也是如此。关于这一点的第一个里程碑式研究是哥伦比亚大学的Maddie Gould在2005年做的，它发表在《美国医学会杂志》（JAMA）上，供感兴趣的人参考。她做了一个实验，询问了一些孩子关于自杀的问题，而没有询问其他人，然后对他们进行了随访。被问及自杀的人并没有更痛苦，并没有更有可能考虑自杀，也没有更有可能从事自杀行为。
And this has been replicated over and over again. It is safe to ask people about suicide. If you think someone might be thinking about suicide, you should absolutely ask them. Easier said than done. People are almost always nervous to ask a question. I study suicide for a living. I've been doing it for 30 years.
这一点已经被反复验证。询问人们关于自杀的问题是安全的。如果你认为某人可能在考虑自杀，你绝对应该问他们。说起来容易做起来难。人们几乎总是害怕问这个问题。我以研究自杀为生。我已经做了30年了。
I still get nervous, admittedly, asking friends and family if I think they're at risk, asking the question for fear of how is someone going to respond? Are they going to get angry or is it going to damage our relationship in some way? But I've also learned more than anything over the past number of years, better to ask the question and have that conversation than to not and then to wonder, should I have approached a subject with them? I found over and over and over again, people in my experience are glad to have been asked.
我仍然会感到紧张，诚实地说，如果我认为朋友和家人有风险，我会问他们，因为担心某人会如何反应？他们会生气吗，或者这会以某种方式损害我们的关系吗？但在过去的几年里，我学到的最重要的一点是，最好问这个问题并进行那次对话，而不是不问，然后想，我是否应该和他们谈谈这个话题？我一次又一次地发现，根据我的经验，人们很高兴被问到。
It shows that you care. It opens up that channel of communication. So even if they say, no, you shouldn't ask me that. They now know you're someone they can go to and talk. It usually helps the relationship much more than it harms it. So what I always advise people to do is I use the acronym A-R, give somebody air, A-I-R. Ask the question and then show interest in the response, whatever it is, and then refer the person. Don't try and do this all in your own.
这表明你在乎。它打开了沟通渠道。所以即使他们说，不，你不应该问我那个。他们现在知道你是他们可以去找并交谈的人。这通常对关系的帮助远大于伤害。所以我总是建议人们这样做，我使用缩写A-R，给某人空气（AIR）。提出问题，然后对回答表现出兴趣，无论回答是什么，然后转介这个人。不要试图独自完成所有这些。
So asking the question, I usually ask it in a way of not just, are you going to kill yourself? I try and lead up to it. And I also don't ask it in a way that's leading a person to say no. I've seen a lot of people say, you're not thinking about suicide. Are you? That then requires the person. It's leading the witness, Your Honor. So I would ask, hey, it sounds like you're really down, whatever situation is, whatever information they're giving you.
所以问这个问题，我通常问的方式不仅仅是，你要自杀吗？我尝试引导到这一点。而且我问的方式也不会引导一个人说不。我看到很多人说，你没有在考虑自杀，是吗？那这就要求那个人。这是诱导证人，法官大人。所以我建议问，嘿，听起来你真的很沮丧，无论情况如何，无论他们给你什么信息。
Have things been so bad that you've thought about ending your life? dine. Have things been so tough, so difficult that you've thought about suicide? And pause and give them space to ask. I wouldn't pull for, don't pull for no as much as you might want to hear no. Ask in a very curious, the way I was taught, calm, dispassionate demeanor. Have things been so tough that you've been thinking about ending your life for suicide and then pause and let them respond? And then demonstrate interest. Not, whof, I'm glad you weren't or okay. Then you turn around and walk away. wow, sounds like that's tough for you, or, okay, I'm glad I asked, please let me know. Demonstrate interest in the person and follow up and, again, signal that it's okay to talk
事情已经糟糕到让你想结束自己的生命了吗？事情已经变得如此艰难，如此困难，以至于你考虑过自杀吗？然后停顿一下，给他们空间去回答。我不会强求，不要像你可能想听到“不”那样去强求“不”。以一种非常好奇的、我被教导的、冷静的、客观的态度去问。事情已经变得如此艰难，以至于你一直在考虑结束自己的生命或自杀吗？然后停顿一下，让他们回答。然后表现出兴趣。不是，呼，我很高兴你没有，或者好的。然后你转身走开。哇，听起来这对你来说很艰难，或者，好的，我很高兴我问了，请让我知道。对这个人表现出兴趣并跟进，再次发出信号，表明可以和他们谈论
with them about this and you're willing to have that conversation. Just as importantly, refer. Don't try and manage everything on your own. Don't try and do it all on your own. Refer the person to a clinician, if they have a clinician, one of their, if it's a child, their parent, their coach, their peers, their siblings. Most importantly, 9-8-8, bring. them to the emergency department, follow up and encourage them to, if they don't have a clinician,
这个话题，并且你愿意进行那次对话。同样重要的是，转介。不要试图独自处理所有事情。不要试图独自完成所有事情。将此人转介给临床医生，如果他们有临床医生，如果是孩子，转介给他们的父母、教练、同龄人、兄弟姐妹。最重要的是，9-8-8，带他们去急诊室，跟进并鼓励他们，如果他们没有临床医生，
you can help them find one. There are therapists finders online. I'm sure APA has has one. ABCT.org has one as well. You can go on and put in your zip code and find a clinician near you who does evidence-based treatment. So there are ways of finding help online if you don't have it readily available. But again, don't feel the need to do it all on your own. This is something we hear from people, especially common in young people anecdotally. Yes, I'm thinking about suicide. Please don't tell anyone. Promise me you'll never tell anyone. I would not make that promise. I have not made that promise. I would say, no, I care about you. I want you to be alive. This is why I asked. And so even if it means losing you as a friend, but I keep you alive, I'm going to go talk with someone about this.
你可以帮助他们找到一个。网上有治疗师查找器。我相信APA有一个。ABCT.org也有一个。你可以输入你的邮政编码，找到你附近做循证治疗的临床医生。所以如果你没有现成的帮助，网上有找到帮助的方法。但同样，不要觉得需要独自完成所有事情。这是我们从人们那里听到的，特别是在年轻人中很常见，非正式地说。是的，我在考虑自杀。请不要告诉任何人。答应我你永远不会告诉任何人。我不会做出那个承诺。我没有做出那个承诺。我会说，不，我在乎你。我希望你活着。这就是我问的原因。所以即使这意味着失去你这个朋友，但我让你活着，我会去和某人谈谈这件事。
I'm going to try and get you help. Well, Dr. Knock, I think that's very good advice. I want to thank you for all the great information you've given us today. This is a very important topic. Great. Well, thank you again for having me out and thanks for covering it. really appreciate all the work you all do. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association.
我会尝试为你寻求帮助。好吧，Knock博士，我认为这是非常好的建议。我要感谢你今天提供给我们的所有重要信息。这是一个非常重要的话题。太棒了。好吧，再次感谢你邀请我，也感谢你报道这个话题。非常感谢你们所做的一切工作。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org上，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Weinerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。
Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。